but if you could have talked to michael  jordan in that moment what would you  have said thank you i didn't see myself  doing you know as a kid but having that  opportunity to be there you know talk to  him introduce myself you know just have  that conversation with him i don't know  what i would have said but yeah i wish i  played in his generation he wished he  would have played in his generation yeah  why like just how he you know go about  the game you know just that mindset he  had i would like to know play against  him you know yeah this time you're not  saying i would have cooked uh i would  have cooked on two you would have cooked  michael jordan nobody got more  confidence than 12.